انا مواطن مخيم البريج يتم استهداف اي
واحد بمشي يتم استهداف المخيم جوا في
شهداء واشلاء ناس مقطع عند صدي ياف عند
النادي عند الوكاله عند الشهداء كل
المنطقه الصغيره بطخ على الناس وعنده وروس
في كمان شهده في كل مكان طياره
سامعها الكوات
بطخ هذخ لله كانت صعبه جدا
زمريه قرب تحت بالخان عن ورده
تق انا رم لساحه من الشاطئ نازحين هلقيت
في البريج وهلق مش عارفين يعني وين
نروح الوضع هنا كثير صعب
و يعني الناس كلها طلعت ومش عارفين يعني
كنا نحاول انه نضل لانه فيش مكان نروح
نطلع يعني بمكان ثاني وهيك بس يعني انه
هينا خلص لانه في اجل الوحد
يضل والله صحينا بدات الليله على صوت
الصواريخ والضرب والقذايف من كل مكان يعني
وكنا محاصرين في الدور ومش قادرين نطلع
عبين ما طلع النهار حاولنا انه زي ما انت
شايف والوضع يعني سيء جدا فوق ما تتخيل
انا واحد من الناس انا من اول حرب قاعد في
داري انا اليوم طلعت اليوم اول يوم في
الحرب بدا
عندي طلعونا من
معسر بلاد امنه اجينا هنا هينا من هين
طلعونا عن صراط رحنا عن صراط مش مكان امن
طول الليل خبط الصغار خايفين نن ايش نسوي
احنا حلونا وين بدنا نروح يا
عمي نزحنا من الشجاعيه طبعا من غزه يعني
شفنا هال الاشلاء وشفنا يعني متنا الف
موته لما شفنا هالمناظر اجينا على الصارت
على مدارس النصرات قعدنا في النصرات
الدبابه صارت ترشق يعني مراه حامل انقطع
على راسها واحنا بنطلع فيها طلعنا نصوت
ونجحنا زي ما انتم شايفين ويعني اقول لك
معيشه غير غ صعبه للغايه وهذا احنا في
السقعه نمنا هان الفرشات ثلج ثلج احنا
نمنا على ثلج
الليله وقت يجينا هان ما لقينا شيء يحوينا
وقعدنا على الارض في عراء لا اكل حتى
الاولاد بياكلوا فلفل احمر قاعدين انهم مش
لاقين شيء ياكلوا اطفال يعني احن كنا
اطفال هنا اولادنا ما فيش كبار اجيت هنا
كذا مره معطي خيمه مش اول مره اجي هنا انا
والحمد لله اج الواحد زينا زي
[موسيقى]
هالناس طلعنا بؤسنا ورحنا على النخيل
وقعدنا في النخيل ق فيشك وسع وجينا ه
بقولوا فيش خيم في وسع بس فيش خيم قلنا له
وين الوسع قال هي ب نظف الكوم وقعدوا
مكانه اللي خمسه ايام الحين لا سكن ولا
اكل ولا مشرب وموت وقصف روسنا وين
الروح وين الروح يا عمي وين
الروح